e
[Aplausos]
se vocês digitar em no Google uma pessoa
legal provavelmente vai aparecer uma
foto da minha mãe minha mãe é uma pessoa
muito legal e se não aparecer fale
comigo que eu vou ligar para o Google
para ver o que está acontecendo lá a
minha mãe foi professora a vida inteira
de aula prefeitura dela no estado a
minha mãe como uma boa vovó amo os netos
a Gabi a Marina João Gabriel a Estela e
a Nina minha filha que nasceu ano
passado e a mais novinha a minha mãe
adora viajar e uma das viagens
preferidas dela foi para besans na
Áustria cidade tem o nosso sobrenome
bervanger mas o que a minha mãe me ama
mesmo é costurar adora pregar o botão de
uma camisa arrumar a barra de uma calça
as sempre fazendo um artesanato
provavelmente se minha mãe tivesse aqui
além dos origamis você seriam ganhar um
é um porta lixa uma bolsinha para
carregar absorvente ela sempre tinha
alguma coisa para entregar para alguém e
eu descobri que a minha mãe na verdade
adorava costurar redes de afeto rede de
acolhimento
no dia Cinco de Março de 2021 a minha
mãe testou positivo para o covid-19 e em
rápidos e intensos
17 dias a minha mãe não deixou e essa é
a mensagem que eu mandava os meus amigos
contando para eles que a minha mãe tinha
falecido e o número 17 Parece que tem
uma perseguição boa comigo diga-se de
passagem porque eu casei no dia
dezessete eu descobri que minha filha
nasceu no dia dezessete a minha filha
nasceu no dia dezessete e desses 17 dias
Acho que o mais especial foi a noite do
dia Dezessete de Março porque a tarde o
médico repetir um exame no pulmão da
minha mãe e eu não dormia no hospital eu
dormi eu ia para casa eu moro em São
Paulo mas eu fui para lá cuidar dela eu
dormi em casa aquele dia eu cheguei em
casa e ele me ligou e disse Alf eu vou
colocar a tua mãe na CTI para fazer um
cateter de oxigênio nela é muito
tranquilo uns três dias na CPI e ela vai
melhorar
e eu falei eu tô pensando em dormir no
hospital então já que ela tá pra você
ter amanhã e ele falou vai eu cheguei no
hospital e eu quando eu cheguei lá ela
me olhou e falou ué que que tá fazendo
aqui Eu não queria dizer para ela que
ela é para você tá aí porque ela não
sabia eu falei a mãe eu cheguei em casa
e eu não quis dormir sozinho e ela
melhor disse que bom que tu veio
no outro dia eu acordei de manhã tomei
café com ela e desci para minha irmã
poder subir para também se despedir dela
no celular para CTI e quando eu tava lá
embaixo com meu irmão conversando com
ele a minha irmã mandou uma mensagem
dizendo a mãe passou mal e foi entubada
dentro do quatro foi um quadro
completamente inesperado para que ele
para aquele dia eu liguei para a
Fernanda é minha esposa que tá aqui é a
menina pegar o primeiro avião de São
Paulo foram para Porto Alegre e a 5
horas da tarde daquele dia o meu
telefone tocou e era o médico dizendo as
notícias não são boas
e eu disse a tua mãe teve duas paradas
cardiorespiratórias o sangramento na
traquéia e o quadro dela é Irreversível
eu simplesmente não conseguia entender
aceitar foi um baque porque eu tinha
dormido com ela tomado o café da manhã
com ela e 5 horas da tarde o quadro dela
é Irreversível
e o meu irmão não tinha conseguido se
despedir dela antes de para CTI e ele
quis até o hospital e eu fui com ele a
gente chegou lá na UTI entrou viu ela
entubada no estado muito complicado e se
despediu voltando para casa esperando o
telefone tocar para aquela ligação
protocolar avisando que ela tinha
falecido
e a gente ficou em casa o tempo foi
passando e eu peguei no sono e aí no
outro dia eu acordei de manhã com uma
mensagem do médico dizendo a tua mãe
incrivelmente melhorou e eu lembro que
eu tava dormindo na casa da minha irmã e
eu saí gritando a mãe melhorou a mãe
melhorou e a gente se abraçou e chorou e
começava ali no final de semana de muita
esperança no final de semana de
resiliência de acreditar de positividade
isso era que eu estava vivendo naquele
final de semana mas olhando hoje Eu Vejo
claramente que aquele final de semana
que a minha mãe ganhou uma sobrevida
foi a última atitude da minha mãe como
mãe ela quis nos dar um tempo para a
gente entender que ela tava se
despedindo ela quis deixar a gente
compreender para dar um ser aquele baque
tão grande e na segunda-feira o telefone
tocou e ela faleceu no dia 22 de Março
Oi e o dia 23 que quando foi a o
sepultamento dela que foi um dia muito
difícil porque a convide não basta toda
a crueldade da Morte ela tem a crueldade
da solidão
Bom dia não tem aquela despedida com a
minha mãe Gostava Tanto De tanta gente
foi só nós no inteiro e aquele dia eu
também aprendi algo que o dia da morte a
gente sempre olha como o Finn mas o dia
da morte na verdade é o primeiro dia de
quem fica porque eu recebi 39 anos com a
minha mãe e a partir daquele dia eu ia
viver sem ela eu ia descobrir que o luto
não é uma linha reta eu ia descobrir que
mesmo na dor mesmo com o luto que
aparece de formas completamente
diferentes a vida continua e eu tive uma
lição muito prática disso uma semana
depois quando eu ainda estava em Porto
Alegre e a minha filha ficou doente e eu
já sei desesperado achando que era com o
vídeo não tinha nada a ver e quando eu
cheguei na pediatra
e na sala de espera só tinha uma outra
mãe com uma menininha loirinha
pequenininha de olhos verdes até da
parecida com a minha mãe e aquela
menininha começou a brincar com ali na
minha filha e a minha filha ela é eu sou
realções públicas adoro conversar minha
mãe adorava conversar e anima é assim
embora ela não fale ela tava ali
brincando com a menininha aí as duas se
divertindo fazendo uma bagunça então eu
olhei protocolarmente para a mãe não é
nem falei Como é o nome dela e ela disse
Alice o mesmo nome da minha mãe
e foi nesse dia que eu entendi que a
minha mãe ia aparecer e a continuar EA
seguir comigo de diferentes formas
é a vida é a antítese da Morte e a
pandemia me ensinou isso da forma mais
literal que tem porque eu ganhei a vida
com a Nina no ano passado e eu conheci a
morte até dentro da minha mãe nesse ano
e a minha filha mama um bebê de pandemia
e como a vovó morava longe elas falavam
por vídeo sempre e sempre que minha mãe
falava com ela fazer assim
e eu e minha esposa a gente olhar eu
falava mãe isso é coisa de velha para os
bebês não gostam mais de bilu bilu bilu
o que ela dizia dava risada minha mãe é
isso aí para não esquecer da vovó e hoje
Toda vez que elas ver as fotos da minha
mãe ela faz Bíblia um
e ela não esqueceu eu fui descobrindo
que se fala tanto em novo normal que o
meu novo normal agora é sem a minha mãe
e eu tive que seguir em frente tive que
aprender a lidar com o luto que aparece
em forma de tristeza de dor de raiva mas
o Lux também aparece em forma de amor de
saudade
tem até Sorriso luto e eu continue
Voltei para São Paulo continue
trabalhando fui seguindo a vida
mas a vida não era mais a mesma senha
minha mãe e eu fui seguindo em frente e
teve um dia que eu não aguentei mais e
eu cheguei no sábado sem tempo a minha
esposa encontrar minha filha dormir e
disse eu não sei mais o que fazer dizem
que tem que fazer terapia eu faço dizem
que tem que chorar eu choro dizem que
tem que ter fé eu tenho dizem que tem
que trabalhar eu trabalho dizem tem que
cuidar da alimentação eu cuido eu tô
fazendo tudo eu não sei mais o que fazer
Oi e aí eu lembrei que quando estava
desmontando o apartamento da minha mãe
eu achei umas anotações dela e tem uma
frase lá que era essa aqui quando eu não
estou bem eu volto para casa fico lá até
ficar forte e conversando com a Fernanda
aquele dia dizendo que eu não sabia mais
o que fazer para ficar bem eu disse a
única coisa que me vem na cabeça é a
gente ir para Porto Alegre passar um
tempo
é porque lá sempre vai ser a nossa casa
e Talvez seja isso que esteja faltando e
na hora ela falou vamos A gente se
organizou e foi passar um mês em Porto
Alegre
e quando eu cheguei em Porto Alegre a
primeira coisa que me deu foi muita dor
da minha mãe não tá no aeroporto e
quando eu fui na casa dela de novo de
abrir a porta mesmo sabendo que ela não
tava não tava lá e era muito difícil era
só constatação da realidade o luto
também vai nos abrindo a cabeça e vai
nos mostrando que as pessoas nos deixam
sim e a saudade física um dia
alguém me disse que a saudade do Lu tu
nunca passa e eu acho que é verdade ela
se transforma
é mas aí quando eu cheguei em Porto
Alegre Eu também comecei a pensar muito
na minha mãe e comecei a pensar aqui que
será que eu vim fazer aqui será que a
gente tem que ter vindo e a minha mãe
como toda boa mãe sempre mandava eu ir
aonde no médico Toda Mãe manda a gente
ir no médico sempre cuida da gente em
2001 eu tive um caso de pneumonia muito
grave quem entubado e em coma durante 10
dias
e por ironia do destino do mesmo
hospital que minha mãe faleceu e toda
vez que ia para Porto Alegre a minha mãe
dizia vai visitar o teu pneumologista
faz uma consulta de rotina com ele faz e
tal e eu como bom filho não cair
e até que dessa vez já que a minha mãe
pedir a tanto eu fui fazer a consulta
com ele quando eu cheguei lá e fiz a
consulta na hora que ele me viu fazer
alguns bons anos continuamos falaveis de
cara o teu caso de comorbidade o teu
pulmão é muito comprometido tudo se
vacinar tá aqui o teu atestado e eu saí
de lá e me vacinei naquele dia e lá em
Porto Alegre a Xepa que aquela sobra de
vacinas era por ordem de chegada e idade
e a minha irmã tava indo todo dia na
Xepa tentar se vacinar porque a idade
dela ainda não tinha chegado e a
Fernanda minha esposa que tava lá
começou aí com a minha irmã foi um dois
três quatro cinco seis dias seguidos E
aí a segunda se vacinou
bom e quando o Fernando chegou em casa
eu me dei conta do que que a gente tenta
fazer em Porto Alegre a gente se vacinar
a gente ia ficar forte nós três porque
agora ainda também a receber os
anticorpos pelo leite materno a gente
estava pronto para voltar para São Paulo
e tentar seguir a vida
É mas o luto não é uma linha reta a vida
não é uma linha reta E lembra que foi
para vocês de raiva eu consegui
controlar muitas vezes a raiva mas teve
um episódio esse ano que não me deixou
controlar a raiva se foi quando
anunciaram que a Copa América EA senha
no Brasil
e eu adoro futebol e não via nenhum
problema em ter jogos de cozinha então
tendo os jogos estavam tendo jogos O meu
problema é a minha raiva é que eu só
queria que eles tivessem tido a mesma
rapidez para fazer uma Copa América para
ter comprado as vacinas porque a minha
mãe faleceu no dia da idade vacinal dela
e eu fiz um vídeo com muita raiva para
obter no meu Instagram falando que era
um absurdo que não tinha teto ter Copa
América e no último dia que eu tava em
Porto Alegre e se voltar para cá o irmão
de minha esposa que jogador de futebol
foi convocado para jogar pela seleção
brasileira na Copa América
é a vida não é uma linha reta e a mesma
Copa América que tinha me sentido fazer
a maior raiva tava trazendo talvez a
maior alegria do nosso ano
o quê que eu ia fazer assistir os jogos
e o Brasil foi passando e foi para a
final no Maracanã
o e as famílias dos atletas foram
convidados prêmio jogo autorizado pelo
Ministério da Saúde e eu que era tão
conta que nem posicionei contra E aí no
Jogo sim eu fui no jogo mesmo sabendo
que eu estava sendo incoerente por ser
contra porque era um momento muito
especial para minha família e daquele
sábado à noite eu vou lembrar para
sempre de duas coisas
é a primeira é da casa da Nina Quando
ela entrou no Maracanã e viu aquele
estádio que estava vazio mas valeu pela
seleção brasileira E o Dindo dela tava
ali
e ela sorria para todos os lados mas eu
vou lembrar também daquele um minuto
ensurdecedor de silêncio quando eu só
olhava para o céu
eu me lembrava da minha mãe que ela não
tava mais ainda
é o último virou de cabeça para baixo
desde o dia 22 Março e fizeram assim e
caiu um monte de coisa do meu bolso mas
a gente vai desvirando também ao longo
do tempo A grande questão que quando eu
vou desvirando eu começo olhar para tudo
que caiu no chão e tem muita coisa que
não faz mais o menor sentido tá no meu
bolso
e o luto para ressignificando toda minha
vida oh lu tu tem sido uma jornada
de acolhimento a mesma rede social que
hoje a gente fala tanto que é um lugar
de ordem um lugar de fake News um lugar
que nos deixa agoniado um lugar tão ruim
foi um lugar que me acolheu de forma
incrível eu fui extremamente acolhido
nas redes sociais por pessoas que eu
conheço e por pessoas que eu não conheço
nem eu comecei a pensar que a rede
social pode ser um lugar mais acolhedor
por quê que o mundo não pode ser um
lugar mais acolhedor Porque que a gente
não pode se comunicar de forma mais
acolhedora
é mas a maior descoberta talvez tenha
sido uma caixinha de amor nova que eu
descobri e ela é representada nessa foto
com os meus irmãos
é porque parece que a minha mãe deixou
um amor guardado para eu usar só no
momento que eu mais precisasse
eu e eu e ele se a gente tá usando esse
amor entre nós três e talvez vocês
possam até pensar que faltava amor não a
gente sempre se deu muito bem e eu
achava que era impossível ter mais amor
e tem o luto nos fez descobrir mais amor
é
e essa é a última foto de toda a nossa
família e se você encontrasse a minha
mãe aqui hoje além de entregar algum
artesanato para vocês provavelmente além
fazer essas perguntas Como vai essa vida
boa a minha mãe adorava fazer essa
pergunta para todo mundo que ela
encontrava e eu fico pensando como eu
vou dizer que a vida tá boa sem ela aqui
agora
a única forma eu consigo pensar
E aí Vivendo uma vida mais acolhedora
e é praticando uma comunicação mais
acolhedora todos os dias com todo mundo
a minha mãe passou a vida inteira
dizendo o Gui é um anjo que Deus mandou
para mim e no dia 21 de Maio desse ano
com ela completaria 73 anos eu fui ver
essa tatuagem
porque eu descobri agora que ela me
mentiu durante 39 anos na real ela é o
anjo que Deus mandou para mim se por ela
pela menina e por toda minha família eu
vou seguir em frente mesmo que a vida
também não seja uma linha reta obrigado
E aí